youtube 2016 leute wir sind bei sieben
minuten und 4 sekunden und wir haben in
diesem video vier placement u leute es
gibt einen neuen trend auf youtube und
zwar wenn ein mittlerweile was nicht
mehr passt auf youtube kann man endlich
was machen dagegen und zwar kann sich
einfach in einem eigenen videos die
videos anschauen die eigentlich mehr
gefallen und sie kommentieren mir fällt
so ein stein vom herzen alter endlich
muss man nicht mehr passiv aggressiv
tweet darüber schreiben was ihm nicht
passt sondern ganz einfach in den
eigenen videos machen genau das machen
wir heute heute schauen wir erst hat man
gesehen
videos von baby und analysieren immer
ein bisschen netzkauf bevor es losgeht
leute möchte ich nur sagen dass alles
was ich in diesem video sage hat sich
auf die kunstfigur babys beauty palace
bezieht und nicht auf die personen
bianca heinicke also es ist keine art
und weise persönlich gemeint alles klar
wir sind auf youtube hier auf ihrem
kanal ich habe mir ein paar videos von
euch empfehlen lassen welche etwas
gehaltvoller sind was places angeht eine
sache muss ich noch machen vorher
jetzt warte ich muss das raus dem aus
einem grund den wir gleich sehen werden
und zwar wenn wir diese seite marion
fällt uns auf dass es mal werden
nikotin ist es nicht irgendein ding
gegen rauchen
warum die wir benötigen leuten dressel
dich was uns auffällt leute baby hat
hier sehr guten hintergrund gewählt um
das zu überdecken aber wir haben 12 34
mal mit rolls auf 1 12 minuten video
jetzt ist die frage was in mitholz ein
paar von euch wissen vielleicht ein paar
von euch bestimmt auch nicht mit den
anzeigen die der youtuber selbst setzt
also man hat bei den video ganz normale
auch die werbung am anfang
die ist ganz normal dabei aber youtube
hat auch die möglichkeit zu sagen okay
sobald das video länger als zehn minuten
ist kann ich selbst noch werbeanzeigen
setzen und ich kann selbst bestimmen wie
viel ich setzen möchte und wer wollte
vier sätzen
das heißt durchschnittlich alle drei
minuten werbeanzeige dieses gesicht wenn
man einfach unendlich viel geld verdient
legen wir los mit dem video zu dem video
wurde mir von euch gesagt dass da wohl
viermal ein placement drin ist ich bin
jetzt ganz einfach ein ratespiel und
zwar spielen wir feinde placement okay
wir beide zusammen und gegeneinander
wer zuerst die playstation hat gewonnen
passt genau darauf achtet genau darauf
wenn die produkte im bild erscheinen wer
zuerst displays und bemerkt hat gewonnen
einen favoriten machten beobachter hat
es schon gesehen aber ich schau mal wie
sie darauf eingeht
ein bisschen geld verdient okay leute
mist wir müssen bis zum ende dran
bleiben
wir müssen bis zum ende dran bleiben was
könnte das bedeuten könnte dass was
damit zu tun haben dass wir vier metro
anzeigen auf dem zwölf minuten video
haben und dass wir uns alle vier
anschauen sollen damit wir möglichst
viele zinseinnahmen hat oder will sie
einfach nur dass wir in dem gewinnspiel
gewinnen ich weiß es nicht
ok ok hab ja aufgepasst leute ich hab da
schon zweimal always gesehen will ich
meine irgendwo auch gehört zu haben von
irgendeinem von euch dass die eventuell
flächen verbinden gemacht hat vielleicht
ist es der erste punkt für mich wir
warten mal ab privatmann erstes
placement leute das ziel gerade eben ihr
habt seid ehrlich seid ehrlich war
schneller als ich finde die kommentar
schreibt ich habe sofort gespottet als
der doppelte stand und jetzt kommt's
unterstützt sich euro ist 1 0 für mich
ich finde es bewundernswert wie
begeistert die über slipeinlagen reden
kann
das sind die allerbesten der welt sind
so hauchdünn am liebsten würde ich
einfach mein ganzes bett nur aus diesen
slipeinlagen 175000 likes es ist einfach
qvc auf youtube leute kennen die qvc das
ist dieser shopping channel wo jedes
produkt was auftaucht als das aller
geilste der welt dargestellt wird das
ist einfach qvc auf youtube und 175000
mal wurde gefällt mir gedrückt dafür für
hügelchen im slip u2 displays mit zwei
displays und leute alter schwede
die kodak moments foto-app meine top ten
lifesaver leute ich muss das auch machen
ihr telefoniert einfach mit unternehmen
sagt dir einfach so york impressum zu
machen ja doof ist nicht an der
placement wie sieht's aus überhaupt dem
nächsten video komplett machen
jörg lange das nächste das dritten
plätzen mache vielleicht ja super okay
machen und das führte krieg mit japan
effekt und dann macht ihr einfach viel
places in einem video
ich bin begeistert bewegt 4players
das war richtig cool das ja eigentlich
perfekt es ist ja eigentlich die geilste
foto app der welt dem moment wenn man
mehrfachen millionärin ist und base de
benutzt okay aber kein keine anwendung
steht nicht so ein produkt nation ist
die frage wie schon die beschreibung
always placement kodak cooking fieber
ist die frage ist das jetzt gucken
fieber leute da steht jetzt zwar nicht
von placement aber wenn wir mal ganz
ehrlich sind baby ist nicht blöd würde
baby in einem favoriten video wo sie für
andere favoriten plätze platzierungen
wahrscheinlich 30.000 euro nimmt einfach
irgendein unternehmen sondern favoriten
platz umsonst geben wo auch der
unternehmensname so klar gezeigt wird
wie hier besteht dhaka lorig
schokobrunnen also das ist schon
eindeutig zu erkennen
in meinem kopf macht es halt einfach
keinen sinn von always keine ahnung
30.000 euro zu nehmen und dann das
gleiche für kalorie kostenlos zu machen
und den unternehmensnamen so zu zeigen
ich persönlich würde dann einfach den
unternehmensnamen überblenden oder soja
es ist es in favoriten video sowie den
leuten zeigen was es ist aber ich weiß
nicht mal
[Musik]
placement nummer drei leute das video
läuft vier minuten 30 wir sind bei place
mit nummer drei was ist mit youtube los
ich bin hart wie sie so alles so
unbegrenzt geil findet alter das finde
ich schon hart ich freue mich dass nicht
das habe ich kein placement das
uninteressanter es gibt immer irgendwo
o2 und jetzt
[Musik]
alter schwede youtube 2016 leute wir
sind bei sieben minuten und 4 sekunden
und wir haben in diesem video vier
placement für vier verschiedene produkte
gesehen ist das geil ich bin einfach nur
geflasht ich bin einfach nur geflecht
von what the [ __ ] und sie findet einfach
alles so geil
sollte dieses blatt papier wurde mir von
nike zugesendet ja das ist von nikes bei
papier und ist einfach das geilste blatt
papier ist es wirklich es ist so cool
man kann so viele tolle dinge damit
machen ich benutze das jeden tag zum
beispiel man kann sich so auf den kopf
legen das ist halt wirklich das beste
blatt papier der welt und es ist von
nike und es ist einfach geil das ist
richtig gut macht auch richtig süchtig
das ist so ein richtiges sucht stück
papier also ihr kennt das ja bestimmt
wäre also ein stück papier hat und jeden
tag sechs stunden davor sitzt und sie
einfach nur damit beschäftigt und es ist
halt einfach so und sucht stück papieren
ist es so schön
ich bin so happy damit und er ist auf
jeden fall von nike ich hab euch zu dem
stück papier oder mal jede menge infos
und die beschreibung gepackt also bitte
klicke auf den tracking linke der
beschreibung ja das ist ein tracking
link weil je mehr leute auf den link
klicken desto besser ist meine bewertung
bei dem unternehmen für die kampagne und
desto eher machen dies noch mal mit mir
damit ich noch mal kohle bekommen kann
ok also mach das bitte ich denke wir
sind für dich da neue gerüche und neue
sorten vom velo leute baby hat im
meeting tag x ist das geil digger mein
leben ist doch gar nicht so schlecht ich
gedacht habe
alter schwede neue biersorten das heißt
vielleicht fanny coconut oder cute
strawberry
diese moment wenn eine instagram seite
für duschen für duschen abgefüllt in
plastikflaschen mehr follower als du
selbst hat video leute ganz ehrlich ich
dachte wir könnten mehr als ein video
heute schauen aber dieses videos so
gehaltvoll alltag mal es geht auf jeden
fall nur dieses video nochmal eine folge
davon haben wollte auf jeden fall
kommend in die beschreibung ja leute das
video war ein experiment ich bin sehr
gespannt wie es euch gefallen hat lassen
eine bewertung da oder unbedingt
bewerten da will ich sehen kann wie es
euch getaugt hat und ein kommentar mit
feedback bis zum nächsten mal dran macht
placement